[Music]
i'm gonna
call you out on something you ready are
you seated
i'm ready i got i got my hold on let me
get my scotch ready
for the fun okay go for it
i'm gonna pull the race card on you are
you ready this has never happened before
on the into the impossible podcast go
for it
uh there is a tendency
for a white person upon
seeing a highly talented black person
to say oh it's a gift it's just genetic
it's just rather than say boy you must
have worked
really hard to achieve that
and that disconnect
manifested in your very question to me
because you it was not even in you to
imagine
that i wasn't good at communicating at
some early point where they said well
how can i get better at this let me
think about this
um and uh here's here's an example of
how it got manifested
okay when i got my first invitation to
appear on the daily show
uh with jon stewart i said oh my gosh
that's dangerous this guy's all in your
face let me watch a few of these shows
so i watched it
and i timed how many seconds he gives
his guests
to speak before he interrupts
comedically
and if you're a politician you've got
your stump speech and you've got to get
it out
and he interrupts it oh my gosh you're
flustered and you're dear in the
freaking headlights
so i said that is not going to happen to
me so i timed this so i said i'm going
to parcel
my information that i'm going to share
in that
in that show in six to nine second
increments
so that when he does jump in the thought
has been completed then we can both
laugh
and then i go on to the next thought and
there's no deer in the headlights
not only that not only that
not only that i monitored how
far back he reaches for a current event
that he will then throw into the mix and
he doesn't go back more than about three
days there's a news
cycling because if he makes a current
event reference and it's not current
then it doesn't hit as a joke you have
to say oh well that happened last week
is that relevant now so i would study
current events for the previous three
days deeply i'd bring that to bear on
those conversations
and i'm invited back 14 times and what
do people say
neil you're such a natural on his show
o'neil the chemistry between you is so
natural well you have a gift
this is what i live through another one
i give a public talk
sorry sorry i have to i have to
interrupt because i have to tell you
something
because part of what my essence is is
expressing gratitude
not only did i know that story about you
i learned it from david spurgle two
years ago
before i myself went on ben shapiro show
when i felt the terror
of that you must have felt the first
thing uh who am i i'm some
astrophysicist from from california
i was going on the show that could be
seen by millions of people by the way
he's very controversial as you know
and i said david what does neil do and
david explained to me
exactly the vignette that you just told
me so i know better than anybody and not
only did
i know that neil i followed the tyson
approach
to being a high stress interview
situation so i just want you to know
i would never underestimate the amount
of hard work you put in and i want to
thank you because you enabled me to
perform
marginally okay not as well as you did
on ben's show but nevertheless i used
the tyson technique and that is that was
very key to my to my success
well thank you and i'm gonna add to that
uh thanks for adding that prefer
for for throwing that in the mix there
so on another occasion i give a public
talk
right and uh and then the people enjoy
it and they clap at the end
and then so i get two responses
typically
all right i'm bending them into two bins
but there are other there's nuances
there as well
one kind of response is you are having
such a good time up there
on stage okay and another response is
you were working hard up there
and to a person those who say i was
working hard or school teachers
because they saw what i was doing and
how i was doing it and why i was doing
it
and they appreciated the invested effort
for what that was
so i'm just saying no i don't think any
of it is a gift
and no teacher in the history of my life
would have said so
um not only that i got another one for
you you ready
uh so i've written yeah are you ready
for working right now
[Laughter]
it'll be published in this afternoon yes
so so um my verbal sats were
okay but again they weren't the kind of
score where you'd
hey watch that person they'll go far
wasn't any of that
well 15 years
after i'd taken the sats and got my phd
and i have a column that i write for
natural history magazine one of the more
honorific things i've done
because that's a magazine that stephen j
gould wrote for and i was we were
bookending the middle section of that
with he wrote on nature and i wrote on
the universe but anyhow
i got a letter in the mail from the
educational testing service these the
purveyors of the
of the s.a.t and just to show you what
of a grip they have on us it was like
what happened to my scores they're still
affecting you
like emotional i said well they must
know something because it was addressed
to
dr neil degrasse tyson so i said okay
some somebody updated their file
and i open it up and it says dear dr
tyson we've read a recent essay of yours
and uh we we liked how it worked and
what it did we want to excerpt these
three paragraphs
for our verbal s.a.t that we were
writing
for the reading comprehension and was
like i wanted to say
[ __ ] you okay that's my first thought
then i said no that wouldn't be
productive and i said okay
uh yes i grant you permission for this
so this is a this is an organization
where i take an exam where my score is
not high enough
for anyone to say he'll go far
and now they're coming to me for my
writing sample to put on a test that
they're going to administer to other
people
maybe that's messed up okay okay
that's just messed up and in there later
on okay a lot of that content would be
called and i
would write astrophysics for people in a
hurry which was like
a press you have it yes thank you for
picking up a copy
um and that was on the new york times
bestseller list for 82 weeks
it was on so long that my next book came
out and they both showed up briefly
together
on the list so so when i hear people
saying oh you have a gift
you must have known this this is not i
don't go through life
relying on what other people say about
my potential
right i had to generate it from within
otherwise i would be deluded
either thinking i'm greater than i am
because family members love you
or less than i am because they're people
who have no clue what they're talking
about
and that's my long reply to your very
simple and direct questions
about what i'm doing with my life and
you know now eviscerates my next
question which also came
courtesy of a fellow african-american
physicist from the bronx who went to
your rival school dewitt clinton
and that's stefan alexander and he said
and often in his life he was pushed
towards athletics and not towards uh not
towards science
and he said that of you too that your
teachers were pushing you towards out so
i did do this research
you know to make sure that you know that
this this is
a common theme and it's just the
question of when i talk to people like
jim gates or
you know when i talk to moya mcteer or
whatever
there are two types i'm gonna not play
the race card because i i can't play the
race card i play the jewish card
sometimes but but i i don't usually do
that
um but what is how is that pressure
cause you're layered on top of that as
well like
not only do you have to do this uh jim
gates or stefan alexander
but you also have to speak for you know
i mean that to me
i've said it to them i've said it to my
friend gentry patrick who's uh
actually engaged to my cousin now and
here in ucsd so he's now
the only relative that's been on the
show i said you guys pay a tax you
african american colleagues of mine you
pay an extra tax i don't have to pay it
but um but i but i wonder you know in
our age right now
um are things getting better our things
improving
um when i'm told that my department is
systemically racist for example
i i push back i hate racist neil i punch
him in the freaking face
but i know that the system has a lot of
lacunae in it
and so what do i do as someone who wants
to do well and doesn't want to say that
you know i'm an anti-racist and
i have to do anti-racism in order to
prove him anti-racist it seems like
michael shermer our mutual friend says
that's a tautology basically
you have any advice for an academia or
scientific research for how to
make it better or maybe by reducing the
burden that african american
colleagues have to have to pay
just at all times ask yourself would you
say this to someone who had lighter
colored skin
would you say this to someone who is
female would you say this to someone
who is just ask if you would say exactly
that same thing
okay well when i give a talk and i have
a white person come up to me say oh that
was articulate
would you say that to a white person no
you wouldn't
right so why are you saying it to a
black person and
i think that's the litmus test just sort
of you know when i'm waiting in line to
get on
the plane and i have a first class
ticket and the flight attendant this
before i was recognizable
the flight attendant would say oh oh
this is the first class line
like i didn't know i couldn't figure it
out on my own and i belonged on another
line
would you say that to a white person
standing in front of you
such as that and this is even if i'm in
a suit and tie so
so that's really i think it works
it works really well and i do i do that
all the time
it's how i see it in others and i have
it i might even see it in myself
and so i i try to and it's it's a
constant editing
but i don't want to say it as though
it's something that
is a chore it's something that is a um
it is a duty it is this way progressive
thinking
i think is what all of us should be
invoking
you